of course the triadic form must not be
regarded as scientific when it is
reduced to a lifeless schema mere shadow
and when scientific organization is
degraded into a table of terms current
rediscovered this triatic form by
instinct but in his work it was still
lifeless and on comprehended since then
it has however been raised to its
absolute significance and with it the
true form and its true content has been
presented so that the notion of science
has emerged this formalism of which we
have already spoken generally in whose
style we wish here to describe in more
detail imagines that that it is
comprehended and expressed the nature
and life of a form when it is endowed it
with some determination of the schema as
a predicate the predicate may be
subjectivity or objectivity or say
magnetism electricity etc contraction or
expansion east or west and the light
such predicates can be multiplied to
infinity since in this way each
determination of form can again be used
as a former moment in the case of an
other and each can gratefully perform
the same service for another in this
Cirque sort of circle of reciprocity one
never learns what the thing itself is
nor what the one or the other is in such
a procedure sometimes determination of
sense are picked up from everyday
intuition and they are supposed of
course to mean something different from
what they say sometimes what is in
itself meaningful for example pure
determinations of thought like subject
object substance cause universal and so
on these are used just as thoughtlessly
and uncritically as we use them in
everyday life
we're going to use ideas like strength
and weakness expansion and contraction
the metaphysics is in the former case is
unscientific as our sensuous
representations in the latter
in Section 50 Hegel is now going to
begin a new progressive sustained
critique of what He is calling formalism
he just finished up with criticizing
several other things including
mathematical cognition and philosophy
that would base itself upon that now
he's turning instead to criticizing
something that's a little bit closer in
time to him his fellow German idealists
and he's not he's not actually attacking
them in my name you have to sort of read
between the lines except for of course
Conte who he's going to mention almost
immediately in in this one and you want
to ask yourself what is he actually
doing here what is what is the center of
this this critique is it purely critical
or is there something that is going to
actually be progressive positive going
forth from this so we want to talk about
the triatic form triad of course yes
triangle three and he says I can't
rediscover this but didn't really know
what he was on to and the question that
we want to pose is is this going to
degenerate into merely a schema that we
can shove anything we like into which is
what he thinks that some of the fellow
German idealists are doing and I think
that Hegel if he were to be around today
he would say that a lot of people who
claim to actually be interested in
admirers on studying Hegel actually do
this with Hegel zone works or is the
triadic form going to provide the basis
for finally making not only philosophy
but science in general scientific so
let's look at what he says he says the
track four must not be regarded as
scientific when it is reduced to a
schema if you're just sort of taking
time
in saying how can we shove this in here
how can we use this to make sense of
things because we need to have a triadic
form Hinkle would say look there's
there's no you know there's there's
nothing that says that you have to have
a triadic form as a matter of fact you
notice that I've got here the famous
Hegelian thesis antithesis synthesis and
you know if you do read through a lot of
Hegel's works you will see him using
triadic forms quite quite often as a
matter of fact perhaps he's a little
schematic about it at times but it
doesn't always make recourse to the
Triad sometimes you know what's going on
is primarily between two things
sometimes it's a whole manifold that is
being addressed or discussed so you
don't want to think that Hegelian
philosophy really boils down to thesis
antithesis synthesis I know that
oftentimes when we're you know helping
out beginners we present it in that way
but we're really doing them a disservice
if they began to if they begin to use
that in a schematic form thinking that
well you know we can put anything we
like into it like you know shirt is a
thesis and what's a shirt without a tie
you know that's the antithesis of it and
what brings it all together Oh a jacket
and now we've got a synthesis you know a
greater whole and on sound you see how
silly that is you can do that sort of
thing all day long but you're not really
doing philosophy you're not really
learning about anything important that
way so he says country discovered this
triatic form by instant what does he
mean there well if you read Khan's first
critique
you're gonna see him talking about the
categories of the understanding and the
categories of the understanding are pure
determinations of thought that allow us
to make sense of things and can't always
had a difficult time explaining exactly
how these categories hook up with the
empirical reality that we encounter and
that's the question that Hegel is
concerned with here how do we
intelligently connect the realm of men
fix or cure determinations of thought
with what it is that we actually
experience act upon re acted upon live
within all of that sort of stuff the
realm of the senses and of the
understanding how do we connect those up
so Hegel says look hot rediscovers this
and in his work that was still lifeless
anon uncomprehending since that it's
been raised to its absolute significance
and with it the true form in its true
content has been presented so that the
notion of science has emerged now he
doesn't mean that that's happening here
in the preface he means that that's
happening through the rest of the book
so you're gonna see triads going through
the rest of the book some like I said
more in some places than in others and
then he says this formalism that we've
already spoken of in which style we want
to print described here in more detail
we're going to do a slightly more
detailed critique imagines it is
comprehended and Express the nature and
life of the form when it's in doubt it
with some determination of the schema as
a predicate so what are we talking about
there take anything that you like again
we'll use this this really silly example
that I just came up with them
you know on the fly shirt so let's call
the shirt the thesis now what does it
actually tell you not really anything
and now we'll call the time antithesis
and you know why did the tie up to be
the antithesis why not start with the
tie as the thesis and then say well you
know you have to have something to hang
the tie on so you know obviously maybe
it's just the collar that's the thesis
you see that this is very arbitrary
there's no intrinsic necessity to this
that's what Hegel is is upset about
that's what he's criticizing here he's
saying that now we're not going to talk
about shirts and ties or
naturally or anything like that let's
talk about the sort of things that these
guys were really fascinated with
electricity magnetism contraction and
expansion east and west and he says you
can multiply these predicates to
infinity you can come up with as many of
them as you like you can cram whatever
you like into these these triads or
really even just dyads and so long as
you're not explaining why these things
are actually connected with each other
you're not explaining anything you're
not giving anybody any real knowledge
you're giving the appearance of
knowledge certainly and you're saying
some things that sound profound but they
don't actually connect up with anything
and provide intelligibility that is a
capacity to understand how the things
fit in with each other so so he says you
can multiply these to infinity in this
way each determination of form can be
used as a form or movement in the case
of an other and can gratefully perform
the same service for another and he
talks about this as a circle of
reciprocity that means that these things
are connected with each other it's
interesting because in the the that
actually fits into two cons categories
myths are inside now what's the upshot
of this it looks as if because you're
using some sort of schema as if you're
contributing to knowledge about
something but the trouble with formalism
is that the content just winds up being
wherever you want to place it so you
don't need to have three you can have
four you could have twenty-eight you
could say something similar about about
you know just one example about the
semiotic square derived by by grimace
and used by people who are interested
semiotics you just stick whatever
content in you want and you're going to
connect things up with each other in
some way or another but does that
actually tell you about the content of
the things that you're trying to make
sense of and Hinkle says no it doesn't
here's here's the problem you never
learn what the thing itself is nor what
the on one or the other is and that we
talks about something else he says in
this procedure sometimes determinations
of sense are picked up from everyday
intuition we we have a world that we in
fact experience you know this is a color
there's other colors in this those are
things that we experience you're hearing
me right now this is you know a visible
representation and an aural
representation it's not in the realm of
you know smell or touch or anything like
that
in any case we pick things up from that
and then we shove them into these boxes
or into you know slots and the schema
and then we say to ourself yes we mean
that but you know in a different way as
Hegel says these are picked up from
everyday intuition but they're supposed
to mean something different from what
they say so what would they mean that's
different
well sometimes we're talking about
determinations of pure thought in the
realm of metaphysics metaphysical
conceptions like subject object
substance clause universal so if you
want to we can say here's just one thing
let's get you know the thesis here will
be subject and the antithesis will
object and this is a very popular one
for philosophy you know how do we
overcome the subject object dichotomy
which one are you actually talking about
are you talking about the one of
knowledge action are we talking with the
fact that subjects can actually become
objects we have to get determinate with
this we actually have to say
what the things consistent instead of
just you know throwing these nebulous
terms around as if we're actually doing
some philosophy and then you know people
can lie and say I don't know what were
the synthesis be maybe it's gonna be
something more can create it's the
person or ago why have that why not have
something else maybe it's God or why not
have we can do whatever we like with
this you can again you can stick
whatever content you like into there and
it will make some sort of sense because
you already have a schema in place but
you're not really doing philosophy when
you do that so he says these are used as
thoughtlessly and uncritically as we use
them in everyday life where we use ideas
like strengths and weakness the
metaphysics is in the former case is
unscientific as our sensuous
representations in the latter this is
not the way to do philosophy this is not
the way to do metaphysics he's saying no
notice he is saying we should be doing
metaphysics
instead of the inner life and self
movement of its existence this kind of
simple determinate Ness of intuition
which means here self-knowledge is
predicated in accordance with a
superficial analogy and this external
empty application of the formula is
called a construction this formalism is
just like any other what a dullard a man
must be who could not be taught in a
quarter of an hour the theory that there
are ascetic stenick and indirectly
aesthetic diseases and as many modes of
treatment and sin still quite recently
such instruction suffice who could not
hope to be transformed in this short
space of time from an empirical into a
theoretical physician the formalism of
such a philosophy of nature teaches say
that the understanding is electricity or
the animal is nitrogen or that they are
the equivalent of the south or north
pole or represented whether all this is
expressed as boldly as here or even
concocted with more terminology and
confronted with such a power which
brings together things that appear to
lie far apart and with the violence
suffered by the passive things of sense
through such Association and which
imparts to them the notion semblance but
saves itself the trouble of doing the
main thing that is expressing the notion
itself of the meaning of the sensuous
representation confronted with all of
this the untutored mind may be filled
with admiration and astonishment and may
venerate in it the profound work of
genius it may be delighted to with the
clarity of such characterizations and
since these replace the abstract notion
with something that can be intuitively
apprehended and so made more pleasing
and it may congratulate itself on such a
feeling of kinship of soul with such a
splendid performance the knack of this
kind of wisdom is as quickly learned as
it is easy to practice once familiar the
repetition of it becomes as insufferable
as the repetition of a conjuring trick
already seen through the instruct the
install ISM is no more difficult to
handle than a painter's palette having
only two colors say red and green the
one for coloring the surface when a
historical scene has wanted the other
for landscapes it would be hard to
decide which is greater in all this the
casual ease with which everything in
heaven and on earth and under the earth
is coated with this broth of color or
the conceit regarding the excellence of
this Universal recipe
each supports the other what results
from this method of labeling all that is
in heaven and earth with a few
determinations of the general schema and
pigeonholing everything in this way is
nothing less than a report clear as
noonday on the universe as an organism
that is as a synoptic table like a
skeleton with scraps of paper stuck all
over it or like the rolls of closed and
labeled boxes and a grocer stall it is
easy to read off as either of these and
just as all the flesh and blood has been
stripped from this skeleton and then no
longer living essence has been packed
away in the boxes so in the report the
living essence of the matter has been
stripped away or boxed up dead we have
already remarked that this way of
thinking at the same time culminates in
a style of painting that is absolutely
monochromatic for it is ashamed of its
schematic distinctions these products of
reflection and submerges them all on the
void of the absolute from which pure
identity formless whiteness is produced
this monochromatic character of the
schema and it's lifeless determination
this absolute identity and the
transition from one of the other are all
equally products of the lifeless
understanding and external cognition
I think that a lot of people don't
actually realize until they spend some
time with Hegel that he can be quite a
funny guy and that the humor in his his
work is often quite biting and satirical
you gotta like pay close attention to
what he's saying you might see it as
just being arrogant or scornful but he's
he's really fusing together criticism
and humor using humor as a kind of
weapon or you might even say something
to leverage open the space in which
genuine philosophy can can come into
play and showing up the pretensions of
false philosophy so again in this
section section 51 the big concern is
with formalism he's continuing the
criticism he began in section 50 where
he began talking about triadic schemas
in this one it's not always going to be
triatic you notice that he talks in
terms of two color schemas you know and
then even a monochromatic kind of thing
at the end so we want to follow this
this out he says instead of the inner
life and self movement of its existence
was what we want to grasp through the
phenomenology this kind of did simple
determinate nosov intuition which means
sense knowledge knowledge of the
sensible world the world in which we
live move experience and like I put here
it's not just an experience world it's
also experience of self but it's also an
experience of others and our relations
with them how are we going to make sense
of that sensible world one way is by
taking some sort of schema and this is
what formalism does and then just sort
of superimposing it on the objects of
sense knowledge and Hegel says they call
this construction but what they're
really doing is just a kind of
analogizing and analogies can often be
very useful but we also have to be
worried about
analogies in some cases whether we are
just sort of you know stigmatizing in a
formalistic way and not really
contributing anything of value and he's
got his first joke here he talks about
esthetic stomach and indirectly
aesthetic diseases and their modes of
treatment this is just one
classification of different kinds of
diseases and he says you know somebody'd
have to be stupid not to be able to
grasp that there's three kinds of
diseases and three different kinds of
treatments and you know they then they
can take the test and they can pass the
class they can you know get their
certificate and wait we got a physician
but they don't really understand
anything of the content that they were
studying they don't even know whether
that schema is actually appropriate to
the matters that they're studying here
you see that Hegel a lot of times people
want to say oh he's so abstract he has
no respect for the real world that's all
idealism no he's actually saying that
you can't just take abstract schemas and
paste them on to the real world you have
to actually look at the real world get
your hands dirty get them messy and then
see what forms of thought might actually
be appropriate to them and then apply
them see what you get out of it so he
says this this kind of formalism of the
philosophy of nature and there are a lot
of people doing philosophies of nature
at the time in part because remember we
talked about the need to make sense out
of the connection between metaphysics
and the realm of thought and the
sensible world that we actually
experience and live in that was a
problem because the Cui's to them by
Kant who you know dealt with the
skeptical worries that other people had
about the external world or reason or
things like that
by bifurcating the new model and the
phenomena and there these are attempts
to overcome that you know a philosophy
of nature is trying to wreak
necked those two now how did they do it
Hegel says you know the formalism of the
philosophy of nature says well the
understanding is electricity what the
hell does that mean does it actually
tell us anything that's as good as today
saying yeah you know consciousness is
brain states just repeat brain state so
often enough and show some MRIs and
sooner or later it'll all make sense
well you know you can do that but that's
not actually good science because you
actually want to take account of what it
is that we actually do experience
and you can do this for anything you
like we could make up crazy silly
examples of red and green and blue
kool-aid and the tastes that they bring
and how those produce different states
of consciousness this is just all just
sort of made-up nonsense and Hegel's
saying that's what these philosophies of
nature really amounted to you know
saying that the animal is nitrogen or
that the understanding is the animal is
equivalent to the North or South Pole
he's joking around here he's saying look
if you believe this sort of stuff then
why not make it anything you like why
not say well you know we got these
pieces of chalk here and we got three of
them so here's the D a D and here's the
mommy and here's the child and we can
make analogies all we want now look you
know here's the we want to get off throw
it in with this here's the oedipal
complex at work see that the daddy the
big piece of chalk it's over here and
the mommy and the child are together but
now that the mommy is over here and now
that the little piece of chalk feels bad
because it you can do this sort of thing
all day if you want to notice that we
actually had to interject some real
content there for this to mean anything
we had to interject some Freud this is
the problem with with this schematic
approach to things so he says now you're
going to get people to like this you're
going to get people to say wow man that
makes sense
he says the untutored mind may be filled
with admiration and astonishment
a venerate it at the profound work of
genius we do like organization we do
like having things laid out for us we do
like having those moments where we say
oh now I see how things fit together the
danger that Hagel sees with with
formalism is thinking that just because
we've arranged things in some sort of
order that we actually have learned
anything substantive about it and so he
says the knack of this kind of wisdom is
as quickly learned as it is to practice
and it gives us a criterion for figuring
out when this is the case does it get
boring
does it get stale do we hear the same
thing repeated over and over and over
again and come to say yeah I know that
song I know how that one goes
I know where that line of thinking ends
you don't need to tell me anymore I
already know how to do it if that's the
case then we're dealing with with
formalism he says we can liken this and
this is where he comes up with another
great joke we can liken this to a
painter's palette having only two colors
notice he doesn't say three colors you
know one for thesis one francha this is
one for synthesis just two two will be
enough good I suppose you could mix them
together and have you know your your
third color or something like that but
now notice how he says this he says
painter's palette having only two colors
say red and green good enough you can do
a lot with red and green one for
coloring the surface what a historical
scene is wanted the counter for
landscapes so we're gonna do a
historical scene you know on the pull in
you know with his generals we're gonna
do that in red now the landscape over
here
let's do that in green what are there
some landscape over here why suppose we
got to put some green over there what if
there's like you know I'll figure maybe
Napoleon was walking around in that what
I will make him read that would make
some really crappy paintings wouldn't it
this is not how art works and you know
though the world that we experience the
world that we want to make sense of
through the you know determinations of
or we're not just saying well thought is
over there and it's empty and you know
boring and sterile you know the world
that we actually do experience and want
to make sense of is multi chromatic even
if it was just black and white we'd be
better off than the red and green that
he's talking about here so he says it
would be hard to decide which is greater
at all this now he's being sarcastic
right the casual use with which
everything in heaven and earth and under
the earth is coated with this broth of
color you know you don't have to have
any talent to just slap colors around
all right you can just get a big can of
paint we need some red over here there
we go now it's smoother the better out
of it no no white showing good to go the
Amaze will just be painting walls but
even even those who are painting walls
have to do some taping so they don't use
everything all messed up right and he
says order the conceit regarding the
excellence of this universal recipe who
would they actually think that this is a
viable way of painting things somebody
who you know doesn't know any better and
he says each supports the other what
results from this method of labeling is
that all in heaven and earth with a few
determinations of the general schema and
pigeonholing everything in this way and
the area targets Fichte you know with
his report clearer than the noonday
Hagel thought that that victim was one
of his predecessors he had you know made
a few advances beyond Conte at least he
didn't think that everything was new
middle that you know there was some sort
of break but he thought that Fichte
degenerated into this kind of schematic
formalism and that it really didn't
illuminate much of our experience at all
so he says it's like a skeleton with
scraps of paper stuck all over it so
imagine the human skeleton and instead
of actual flesh and nerves and
and fluids and pick whatever else you
like you just have a bunch of post-it
notes you say here there would be some
muscle here there would be a sin you
hear there would be a nerve no I suppose
you could come to understand something
of that in a very imaginative way if you
actually knew what muscle was or sinew
or ligaments or you know any of these
sorts of things but if you don't already
know that it's not going to be very
helpful is it
he has another example too since it's
like rows of closed and labeled boxes
and a grocery store they're easy to read
it's a nice filing system but you don't
know anything after you you look in the
inside these drawers you know for those
of us who remember card catalog systems
and libraries now you have electronic
systems it's not the same thing to look
at the entry as it is to actually go get
the fork now is it even the table of
contents you can't figure out what a
book is just by reading the table of
contents or the back blur or something
like that you actually have to read the
bar and it's the same way with the
natural world it's the same way with our
experiences it's the same way even with
the world of thought this sort of
formalism is not even adequate to for
human beings to understand their own
thinking or how other people think as
well
so it says not only is this you know
troublesome because it's too abstract it
actually ends up giving way to a
monochromatic ism that is everything
ends up being the same color and you
know he talks about white in this case
you know the white that's pure
formlessness and there you know we're
talking about the abstract absolute that
that some people get into which is
really just their feelings sort of
projected out into reality I would
actually say you guys all remember when
you were a kid and you had paints
you like this mixing the yellow and blue
makes green and I can like add some
white to it now it's light green this is
really cool man I wonder what happen if
I mix them all together
and then you got that ugly brownish gray
color I don't know what to call it but
other than say you know crappy modders
those lines that's what this does
because sooner or later it all just
blends into one thing and you know I
think the greatest indict mint of this
kind of formalism Hegel will just sort
of hints at this but I think that this
is something that you can take from this
that kind of formalism gets awfully
boring and why do we get bored because
we think there's something more than
this something I'm not getting right
here where I am that's what makes this
place boring I'd like to be over there
so Haney was saying you know what do we
need in order to do that we actually
need the concept that's that we need to
make sense out of our sense experience
of the world of nature of others
ourselves the processes of thought
history all those sorts of things we
cannot reduce them to schemas even if
it's the schema of thesis antithesis
synthesis